after witnessing the full-blown circus
of the RNC last week it's clear that the
future of America rests solely in the
hands of Hillary Rodham Clinton look
Hillary we are at a level red
apocalyptic joke and we desperately need
you to keep us from imploding into the
abyss girl all right listen to me I'm
serious girl if you don't turn this
thing around Donald people that lured us
up in here but I met someone at the
White House Correspondents Dinner who
can give you some guidance okay so
please welcome the nightly shows
political campaign strategy expert DJ
Khaled
let's up blast-off his time it's me DJ
Khaled you know me four major keys major
keys of success in the music business
and in life and I got major keys in
selection there Lexington's success with
Hillary Clinton so y'all ready for some
keys major key number one Beach's debate
dang tight you know Trump's gonna fight
dirty but if you come swinging with that
you know that the uppercut in that fool
knockout you're gonna be I make your key
number two Hillary you're a boss now
when you're in the White House this town
you're not this is the first lady you're
not just a secretary of state you're the
number one you are that special car
major key getting endorsed by Barack
that's my guy that's the door and that's
a major key but a little Ciroc to take
the edge off it's a nice five
major key number for DJ counter the king
of the anthems the king of snapchat is
officially endorsing Hillary Clinton we
the best team take out a major key and
Hillary do me a favor you can go to
iTunes right now pre-order my album and
it comes out July 29th
Hillary that's a major key
you